welcome to this episode of uxd where we
will highlight one of the three commonly
missed opportunities for applications to
deliver delight to their users
this is the third and last part of the
three steps to awesome series
I'm your host Nazmul Idris a developer
advocate passionate about design and
mobile and I have with me a very special
guest thanks as well
I'm Patrick larva I'm a UX researcher
here at Google I've been working on
mobile for years and I have lots to say
awesome
so make sure to create applications that
are actually useful and add value to
people's lives so forth before thinking
about the best interaction design or the
best visual design for your application
or even the best engineering or the best
feature set it's really important to
first validate your assumptions about
whether users actually need your app in
the first place
it sounds kind of crazy but you really
have to validate that assumption first
and set the goals correctly so build
applications that people actually want
to use and then delight them with an
amazing user experience getting the
details of that right is going to be a
different series but I think that we can
start here with some real basics about
that you can use to make sure that this
is true and the first thing to remember
is usability really is job 1 for every
app developer out there this is these
are some of these things are gonna sound
super basic and you say well these are
things I already do but just check just
make sure that you're you're thinking
about this the first thing I want you to
think about is what are the physical
constraints and what are the physical
possibilities the form factor I'm
designing for tablet phone what do you
what what is it that you're designing
for these are not these are not similar
they are both different from laptops and
where they're both they're both devices
that are that live with app based
ecosystems that doesn't mean they're the
same think about the vehm the very first
tablet like device that came out the
Kindle these are optimized for reading
they look very much like books and in
fact we know that this this is why
people are buying these tablets they're
they enjoy reading books they need
riveting magazines they enjoy reading
all kinds of content that's not
necessarily true for mobile for mobile
phones you can read a novel on a
smartphone
going to be reading that novel on your
mobile phone and this is just this is
one of the one of the subtle but really
really important differences that you
need to understand about form factor
think not just about how users interact
with what they see on a screen but you
can also think about how information
gets to the device and comes back out of
the device
text is speech and voice input are
really important to think about they're
really novel ways of interacting with a
mobile phone if you're not familiar with
it familiarize yourself with Google now
has some awesome examples of how with a
mobile device the kind of device people
are often using while they're doing
other kinds of things you can use you
can say how long is that goal how long
is a Golden Gate Bridge as you're
perhaps pedaling across it and it will
speak back to you and say it is I'm not
a mile and a half or whatever it is yeah
so this is a this is a novel but
entirely appropriate way of using
text-to-speech and voice input on a
device like that may not be the best
thing to use on a tablet entirely
depends a lot on the situation but the
form factor between these two kinds of
devices has vast implications that often
people are not thinking through do not
attempt to just reuse smartphone
applications for tablets it's a
fundamental mistake yeah exactly I think
to your point if the difference in usage
between smartphones and tablets on the
go on mobile devices like smartphones
people have really really limited
attention to devote to these particular
devices because they're also taking in
their environment and so on so it's not
appropriate to make big big demands of
their attention while they're on the go
and using your application whereas in a
tablet maybe you're at home the context
is very different and so you can then
optimize things more for content
consumption rather than content creation
or even or even things that you need to
do tasks cuz need to execute on that's
right you know um this is a really good
point there are lots of studies that
show that the smartest most switched on
user who really wants to interact your
app has a more limited attention span
and a more limited has just basically
less memory to use when using a mobile
phone than when using other kinds of
device
keep this in mind it's not that the user
is different it's that the device
imposes this difference when you've got
a mobile phone you're also attending to
the environment you're attending to lots
of different things this reduces the
amount of attention this reduces the
amount of brain power a person can bring
to whatever app they're using so this is
really important to think about because
I know a lot of you have heard or
thinking about or are currently using
responsive design and responsive design
is a fantastic engineering fix but I do
not want do not think of it as a design
solution because it is not just because
you can take that novel and put it on a
mobile phone doesn't mean you should do
not just reflow reflow web pages on a
mobile because that because you can use
responsive design think going back to
that that novel think about it on a
mobile phone with a person's reduced
ability to attend a person's reduced
attention span versus reduced memory the
table of contents makes is going is
going to work really well something
where you're going to select between
several options and you go you go to
some other kind of content the novel a
chat the inside of a chapter completely
inappropriate so just because you can
put lots of text on a phone does not
mean you have the responsive design does
not in any way optimize text for mobile
devices it simply puts that text on
mobile devices that is the beginning of
your job it's not the end exactly you
know I think one thing this is I want to
talk a little bit about cowboy design
lots of people like to leave their
signature lots of people like to have a
strong brand presence it is a wild wild
west out there with app design lots of
you know this you've had lots of apps
that you look at and say wow I have
absolutely no idea what this is or what
it does this is not a way of making your
user feel welcome because your user is
not going to feel in control they're not
going to feel like they understand
what's going on if you the the reason
for conventions for platform conventions
isn't just the straitjacket everybody
into a series of of design patterns that
that
that met otherwise make no sense the
point is to make everybody feel
comfortable everybody feel in charge of
what they're doing in turn a lot learn
and internalize those design guidelines
you sometimes have to deviate as we said
we've certainly had their episodes
sometimes you have to deviate you should
do so purposefully and thoughtfully if
you're not sure how to approach this
find a coder buddy and go through the
guidelines until you thoroughly
understand them
remember that users expect objects to
behave in a certain way and there's
absolutely no reason to confuse or
befuddle your user and when you're going
to deviate do so but do so in a very
thoughtful and purposeful way the other
thing about that I want I just want to
say about apps is that you want to know
about location and generally when app
designers think about location they
think GPS I want you to think about
internal location does the user know
where he or she is within your app am I
on the homepage in mine a content page
where am I
where can I go from here where can I go
next and what will I do there this is
actually a fundamental heuristic and you
can you can and should be applying it to
walkthroughs of your app before it gets
released that makes sense and I know a
lot of you out there already know this
this is super super basic but it's
surprising how many people fail to
attend to this fundamental super basic
aspect of design please be sensitive to
the 48 minimum touch target size when
building anything on a mobile device and
by the way that 48 that's for the actual
touch target you need a buffer zone
around that touch target as well because
you can't see it out there in video land
but my fingers are kind of big and if
you don't have an appropriate buffer
around or you need a zone around those
tap targets to keep your user from
inadvertently it's touching the wrong
thing exactly so I think along these
lines of of touch targets prototype on
papers a really good application for
Android and iPhone
that encourage you guys use you can
basically take pictures with your camera
off actual screenshots or basically
wireframes or anything that you're
drawing on paper you essentially just
take pictures off them and then wire
them together and then create a flow
that allows you to interact with
different parts off those scanned images
so it's a really really good way to test
out your design make sure that you've
gotten the some of these touch targets
right before you actually do the
expensive part of actually prototyping
it and developing it so I hope you
enjoyed our episode today just remember
by following our three steps you too can
avoid common pitfalls and make awesome
applications also if you haven't already
please join our UX community on Google+
where we curate information about all
things that are related to UX what's a
cold
what's the community called it's called
UX design for developers and the QR code
is actually on the screen along with the
with link for it so thank you Patrick
for being on the show Thank You Desmond
for having me thanks for watching join
us next time and goodbye